here's Nancy Pelosi but on things like
sending you know those fourteen hundred
dollar checks putting cash out there I
mean didn't that end up contributing to
inflation do you have any regrets about
the bills you passed and how you
structured them no absolutely not
because this that was necessary for
people to survive our purpose was that
it was inflationary
but the point is is that when you reduce
unemployment it's inflationary that is a
fact
all right first off she's starting to
look like Michael Jackson in the later
years that's just the thing I don't
again I don't know why all the Democrats
start looking so insane I don't know why
my theory on it would be something like
this you know Jordan Peterson often
talks about how when you're lying all
the time your face actually starts to
show it the misery you can see it on
people there's a certain misery you can
see sort of the the what the end result
of the Endless dishonesty is and I think
these people are so dishonest they're so
it's it's just such Evil Within them at
this point that the facelifts and
everything else is to combat that but
then it just it's it's sort of the
physiology versus the the chemicals and
I don't know what's going on anyway she
looks like Michael Jackson
um yes lady if you give all these people
fourteen hundred dollars and you're not
giving it to them because it's their
money in the first place and you keep
spending all this money so money has
less value than the money that you're
giving back to the people who you stole
it from isn't going to really help the
economy or help the people but this is
what they do they pretend they're nice
while you're voting for them to control
you please govern me harder please I
vote for you to take my money and then
give it back to me and smack me on the
button send me on my way but man this is
all good you should be feeling good
about today's show because the point is
no one is buying this nonsense nobody is
buying this nonsense and again the polls
are bearing it out but suddenly as I
showed you before Joe Biden doesn't
believe in polls and I don't think Nancy
Pelosi believes in polls and here's a
little more with Pelosi on what's going
on with inflation and the fact is is
that uh when I hear people talk about
inflation as I heard them there we have
to change that subject inflation is a
global phenomena phenomenon the EU the
European Union the UK the British have a
higher inflation rate than we do here
it's not the fight is not about
inflation it's about the cost of living
oh it's not about inflation it's just
about the cost of living nothing they
say has any meaning it doesn't mean
anything guess what when inflation is
high the cost of living goes up right
when inflation is high and your money is
less valuable then you have to spend
more money to get the same things
whether it's your rent or to buy a car
or to buy some chicken thighs like that
is how it works but I like that at least
at the beginning she was somewhat honest
like we got to change the topic they're
talking about inflation could somebody
talk about my eyebrows you see what I
just did here I mean this is serious
stuff but again she just simply does not
believe that people don't like Democrat
policies and that it's coming out in the
polling why why don't the American
people according to the surveys trust
Democrats but instead trust Republicans
well let me just say one of the you
talked about what you perceive to be a
change of momentum let me just tell you
what I have seen over this past month I
don't subscribe to what you said that
they don't trust us
let me just say
I don't
my face is falling off I'll cut the
commercial
I mean Jesus Christ so okay so they
don't believe in the polls well keep not
believing in the polls lady keep going I
mean I really want you guys to keep
going with it you know like keep going
with all your bad keep going chopping
off genitals no states rights high taxes
crashing the economy Warren you keep
going keep going and we're going to show
you uh in about two weeks where where
we're all at with the rest of this